all right Jessica is with us in Phoenix
Arizona hi Jessica how are you hello I'm
gone pretty good yourself better than I
deserve how can we help today um well
I'm just starting to listen to you guys
and I'm just starting to start with the
snowball and getting everything together
but I was wondering if I should just
focus on getting my uh my savings
together and the debt snowball and then
start investing or should I just start
because I have nothing invested at all
although uh 23 and what's your income um
I just our new job but it should be
about 30 on a grand a year good for you
and how much debt do you have uh almost
6,000 on what on uh Oh in my sister
money and credit cards and phone car
loan nope I paid I pay my car good
student loan they catch my car I know
okay good so six thousands it with a
thirty thousand dollar income Chris
Jessica jump all over your debt honey I
mean I'm proud of you number one being
at 23 years old and being in tune to
this your financial future can look
totally different but what I would do is
knock out the phone debt knock out the
money you on the credit cards and the
money you owe to your sister and then
you can start to get focused on RIT on
really building up a fully funded
emergency fund and then you can start to
invest and the reason why Jessica is you
know people in this day and age can't
focus right I mean people are running
around all over the thing trying to do
ten things at once which means you're
ineffective and a lot of things so
follow the baby steps I'll tell you what
I'm gonna even give you one of Dave's
books and I'm gonna send you one of mine
too because I want you to jump start on
this and I know you can do this but stay
focused and do me a favor call and close
down those credit cards and cut them up
don't keep one just for emergencies
right no more of that stuff because when
you when you use a credit card you're
making your money their money right
interest that you pay as a penalty and
you don't want to be penalized you want
to live your dreams
so the book he's sending you is his
retire inspired book which is what
you're heading toward you were asking
about how to do that and the book of
mine is called the Total Money Makeover
and it shows you what to do first what
to do second what to do third and so on
we call that the baby steps and it'll
give you very detailed now if I give you
two books you know the danger about a
free book is no you don't read it so if
I send you too close I read okay if I
send them to you gonna read them yes sir
all right very well
you hang on I'll have Kelly pick up
we'll get you to tae gyoon await your
stuff I noticed that you have just one
good job just rolls off the tongue there
man
just like I can't ever tell you come on
here you cost me money I don't know
what's up with that oh that's good
though I love to hear you know they're
saying Dave Millennials aren't doing
this stuff they are doing it listen ever
tension that study at Ramsey solutions
and we see them the Millennials are
focused they're listening and they've
got so much time in front of them
they're rich a real clear delineation
mark with Millennials they're either
doing it or they're freaking close right
there one day they're not none of them
are in the middle no they don't know
just kind of hang out no end there
either
they're either bad and they're good at
that or they're good and they're good at
that I mean they whatever they do they
do it so we love Millennials around here
we got a bunch of them on the team so
good stuff
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 income
you